[Music]
hello everybody it's me Pete Holmes and
welcome to the Conan after hour stand-up
series presented by Pepsi NEXT where we
showcase some of the show's favorite
comedians
tonight's performer is a writer for
Conan who you all know very very well
please welcome our good friend Deon Cole
everybody
whoa this is happening how's everybody
doing everybody all right welcome to the
black episode that's what the title of
this episode is the black episode right
here that's right
I'm a writer here on Conan and I'm the
only black writer that's here and it's
cool but sometimes I get tripped out
sometime because any time the other
writers have any black question they
think I got the answer for for real I
will be on the writers session this is
me right here they'll be like wow we're
here the rapper 50 Cent's got shot nine
times I know that had to hurt like I
ain't never been shot I don't know I
live in Beverly Hills I don't know what
they do I hear a black cat is bad luck I
wanted as a black cat go through more
stuff than regular cats
like I don't know the struggles of a
black cat
I don't know cat civil-rights I don't
know I know all black men can't have big
penises and being the only black you got
to be on point you can't mess up you got
to be on point with everything you do
when you the only black person so we're
like one time we was working here like I
just had we was writing the script one
time and I messed up and I balled it up
right had trash and I was throwing it
away in the garbage can it was right
here and I shot it and missed and other
white writers was like that's why he
works here no defense the wind wasn't
blowing and he missed that shot I just
don't trust him I tell you I don't trust
like it was trash what is wrong with you
I don't it's just one guy that our work
with he always come to me and talk to me
about black stuff I don't know why it's
just weird yeah just come to my office
and be like hey you have his group
called Bell Biv DeVoe I'd be like yeah
people like aren't they awesome did he
leave yeah just come by my office and
moonwalk like you remember this
[Applause]
what does that have to do with anything
living out in LA you really gotta like
work out and stuff like I mean like when
I first got out here they gave me this
train I like I really didn't want that
East came out to me yeah we're gonna
work you out we're gonna work on your
eyes your eyes the most important thing
you can't eat late at night or you'll
get fat and I'm like I'm gonna eat late
at night he was like you're not supposed
to I'm like well why they put a light in
the refrigerator
smart for that food I just found out
women are crazy I'm serious they are
nuts fellas I know you'd be going
through your relationship problems like
my girl I don't know what's wrong what I
we just can't get along she crazy you
can just ask women and they'll even tell
you like for real there's any crazy
women in here right now make some noise
if you thought you got to be crazy to
admit you're crazy
I just girl come over my house one day
it was late right we was drinking all
night I was trying to be nice you
shouldn't be driving home so I went to
got some sweats and a t-shirt I was like
here you can stay here and sleep tonight
you know she was like oh you just want
to have sex with me I'm like no I don't
she's like yes you are I'm so sick of
men playing these games you know what
i'ma flip it up tonight I'm gonna act
like the guy and treat you like the
woman so you see how this feel all right
you want to ask sex let's have sex and
push me on the bed it jumped on top of
me and I'm like I wonder like that she
was like shut the hell up and just not
right
[Laughter]
is she got up she was like now I'm going
to play playstation for four hours this
she said now I'm ready to leave and
ain't never coming back
and I'm thinking to myself this chick
don't know how awesome this is right now
I was like you gonna call me she was
like forget you marry this heifer right
here and women if you live in a bad
neighborhood let somebody know you live
in a bad neighborhood all right find
somebody drop you off at your home and
they leave and the man get his car shot
up and stuff messing around with you yo
bad neighborhood I went out this girl
one time she had me meet at this Mexican
food restaurant that was black owned
called Casa de Pookie's or the chicken
fajita they brought my fajita dating
through gravy on my fajita side order
grits I might look just wrap my food up
all right I'm like look sweetheart I'm
ready drop you off at home and I tell me
where you live at she was like keep
straight make a right I'll pull up in
front of house I'm like oh you live in
the projects I know it ain't no problem
with you living in the projects and
stuff
it's just the fact that uh all these
people keep walking around my car I
can't keep my eye on everybody
around my car hi I'm paranoid right now
I don't need this she told me don't
worry about them just walk up to her
door I'm like walk you to your door
woman who gonna walk me back to my car
I'm not taking no more pictures with no
more thugs if your thug don't ask me to
take a photo with you
thugs never smile in the picture I was
in New York did the shows all these
thugs outside yo be use funny tail get
over and take a picture with us on my
man I'm tired as I get over to take the
picture I'm like all right quit howling
at me all right I get over there
everybody in the photo is like this I'm
the only do like this
I'm looking at the picture like damn
y'all could have told me I wasn't gonna
smile now and look like I wanted a
picture with y'all Michael Jackson died
that was said I'm a Michael Jackson back
in the day with Pepsi he's doin Pepsi
commercials though it was sad when he
died cuz my son at the time he was 7
years old and he wasn't too familiar
with Michael Jackson you know and at the
funeral on TV and had a picture of
Michael on the screen and my son came in
the room he was like daddy who's that I
said Michael Jackson and then I showed
another picture of him my son was like
who's that I said Michael Jackson then I
showed another picture of my son's like
who's that and I said Michael Jackson my
son was like you're kidding me
I turned to Roseanne my son came back
getting out like is this Michael Jackson
- so black man you don't
[Music]
every time see a black person so where's
all white people a what are you doing in
[Applause]
are you lost I'm just serious check it
out I think America is one of the
greatest countries in the world but I'm
telling you this America isn't cool off
this coolness you know America used to
be super cool like back in the 50s like
James Dean well back in the 50s it was
cool for white folk but you know what
I'm talking about right at a cool feels
like Chevy's and Levi's and all that it
was great cool super cool nowadays just
saying cool was too many laws you know
laws just break down the coolness you
know like when you ride a bike you gotta
wear a helmet elbow pads knee pads I
can't pick up no women wearing this I
look at you're responsible this ain't
cool like that and when we come to
jaywalking do you think how you gonna
tell me I can't walk across the street
especially when there's no traffic
coming do you know how stupid you look
just standing it it ain't a bird coming
through nothing and you have to stand
there and wait on the light to turn and
look across the street and just daydream
about what you're gonna do when you get
that I can't wait to get across these
doughnuts go see your mommy and I can't
go nowhere and people look at you stupid
if you just walk if you just be like
hell with this a wall people be like now
I got a walk across the street when the
little white man show up and tell me to
walk yes it's a perfectly good colored
hand that's up there like this all I
have to do is turn around I'll be like
come on brother you come on across and
Bianco thank y'all so much
[Applause]
bianco thanks everybody good night
[Applause]